and will magnus stop to give a comment  uh with you sweater uh let's find out  he's walking by is it okay for a quick  chat here my name is yeah sure how are  you feeling today firstly uh well uh  quite a quite a lot better than  two days ago a little bit better than  yesterday so  do you get extra motivation by seeing  prague winning  in three games for three matches in a  row  yeah clearly uh  clearly i need to win this match  and and how would you summarize your  first game today  uh a bit  a bit chaotic i think um  uh he made a poor choice early on when  uh he went for all these exchanges which  just left him with a considerably worse  position but then he fought really well  and probably didn't play uh precisely at  the start uh  i think it was uh was a draw for a long  time but uh  this and end games are notoriously hard  to defend good luck thank you